this is bro dang why do it to us bro why
you do it to us Lord that [ __ ] looks
that thing is real
you thought you talking about that
[ __ ] 24-hour fitness whoa zoom in on
that champ no y'all a zoom in chin is
there dick yryr knees or it's a man why
are neat is a man there's nothing there
go back dude that is a woman bro no
going on the face dude
that's a woman on vamo goon dude that's
a woman on hormones dude that's Johnny
Carson that's a woman on hormones bro
this is Skerritt top this lady dude dude
this looks like look at the hand zoom in
on the hands chin it says a lot you know
what says Gold's Gym that's what her
hands say who's a really strong person
named Michael this looks like Bret
Michaels Bisping dude look at this
[ __ ] picture again okay
look how jacked and strong and also Bret
Michaels this person is it looks like
tits you don't know are not tits man you
can't do that and just say it's tits no
you can't hide - this looks like a game
at Dave and Buster's - that's going on I
don't know where to go with this bro I
just what is going happen on look at the
belt the crud of Mankiw look at the
whole [ __ ] you know we get the
powerful jaw look at the [ __ ] dick in
the front look at the man hands look at
the 24-hour fitness body baby that thing
is about picograms you talk about miss
Pico right now that's miss Piko Piko
baby oh this is a lady who's definitely
like doing lines of uh probably garbage
a sauce of playing with a [ __ ] ranch
table um lines a plant-based protein
powder you know in her car she looks a
type that had kissed you like the girl
did you in middle school
you up as the Booya oh I chose for era
su ro yeah she would [ __ ] wrap my
legs on her it was so weird
dan you can't hit him no no huh she was
very very nice girl too you look like
your name's Tanya but goes by Tony they
actually call her uncle Sheila I told
you look at those hands baby oh there's
no look at the arm look at the dude that
is a woman who has been on many many
hormones yeah although that chest that
makes it different don't it yeah see
that stomach chest area that's very
massive right bro and those tits are way
too hard look at that arm it's not a
woman's arm look at the bottom of that
arm going into the hand that is eight
you know what deal you're right bro
thank you brother
don't [ __ ] touch me especially when
you have one eye well and we're looking
at a uncle I'm putting the patch down on
this lady she doesn't judge Hatchett
over my eye I for this one is that
there's the Weiner for the flounce and
face - Kelsey right for sending this one
in thanks for a splash uncle Sheila is
it really it looks like they're in uh
and looks like they're in Denver but
here's the thing I'll tell you it was
this Spokane Washington this beautiful
little you know you appreciate the hard
work now clearly a gym rat it's really
clearly a gym rat bro and clearly takes
her protein at the right time of day
right after a workout has it ready to go
and the sacrifice and discipline to get
that body is nothing we should all just
pass by I agree I mean it's easy for me
to sit here with you know one eye in the
[ __ ] and an erect penis and judge
this person and uh but to actually get
out there and do the work to shave your
arms and shoulders touch a shave your
tip every day yeah and dress like just
you know like Wyatt slurp every day to
dress like the [ __ ] didn't Naked Cowboy
in New York every day you're alive
alright it's a dress like [ __ ] that's
like a WWE Diva during your normal life
yeah I mean this is definitely I thought
this was Brett might be the first p2
I thought was rock a love promo I
thought they're bringing the season back
yeah this is like crack rock I love all
right shout out to the and oh yeah Thank
You Cheryl Sheila back up my broccolini
get your life together